all right so
do you remember when Elon Musk said that
Teslas would soon be able to just drive
themselves across the entire country
with no one in the driver's seat thanks
to full self-driving I remember that too
but that's not real yet but this demo
that I'm going to start right now is as
close to that as I can possibly get I'm
gonna hit this button on the steering
wheel
and I have the navigation set and this
car will now drive me to the studio I
will attempt to interrupt this as few
times as possible
but as you'll see it has its strengths
and weaknesses and there are probably
going to be times where I do have to
either put my foot on the brake or take
over steering or do something for the
car
the number one reason I've had to do
that so far is not safety but actually
just embarrassment like it just slammed
on the brakes seeing that car backing up
and now it has the blinker on for some
reason but it's way too early
it needs to go all the way to the stop
sign
now it's going
and then it used to handle a roundabout
so pedestrians oncoming cars there's a
lot going on I have a feeling I'm gonna
have to interrupt on this roundabout
we'll see there's a lot happening but
the bread and butter is definitely
highway driving so we'll see you get to
that point and we'll see what it does so
now it's creeping forward and it has to
deal with New Jersey drivers which is
kind of a lot visibility cars moving in
and out
I am a little bit nervous it's she's
waving me on thanks but it's also
looking at that car so it might hit the
brakes but it doesn't Okay heads to the
roundabout Dives right in
hits the brakes for some reason
makes it through
okay hits hits this turn for some reason
oh that's the okay that's the navigation
and we're off
this is like
there's a lot going on here and I'll
talk you through it through this whole
uncut video we have the camera facing me
we have the camera facing forward but
I'm gonna try not to
cut through them too much and I will not
cut anything out of this drive
so right now the speed limit according
to the signs that it's red is 35 miles
an hour
and it can default to up to 10 miles an
hour over the speed limit so now it's
comfortably going 45 totally fine
there's lots of cops like this one that
don't seem to mind so that's cool
uh but it's also coming up to a turn
here so it's gonna have to slow down put
the blinker on and hit that left turn
so it slows down puts the blinker on
it's got some oncoming traffic and it
also has this car here over the line but
we'll see what happens
New Jersey drivers tend to not let you
in but
they're letting me in
so it makes the turn don't hit anything
okay
oh man apply a light Force so every once
in a while you're gonna see it light up
the screen in front of me and it says to
apply a light Force to the steering
wheel because the idea is this is just a
little bit more than regular traffic
aware cruise control
so it wants to make sure my hand is
still on the wheel so it wants a little
bit of firm pressure on the wheel every
once in a while
this is a hard merge this is a highway
speed Route 17 entrance ramp
and I'm not so sure how it's going to
handle this one let's let's give it a
chance here there's also a car really
close to the edge
so autopilot's creeping forward and
checking for visibility
and I have a feeling it's just going to
wait until they get a red light over
there because it says on this screen
it's going to try to get into the second
lane
and that's just not happening
at
the speeds I've seen this go
so I'll just say that the most common
interference that I've had to do like I
said was by embarrassment
there we go it's because it tries to be
very cautious so it just went out into
the third lane there which is fine
because there was no one behind me but
now it's speeding up
and it says upcoming Lane change to get
into the left lane because we'll need to
make a left-hand exit off of 17. tap to
cancel if you want but I'm totally cool
with that it slowly speeds up 60 miles
an hour max
and it's comfortable
there's the blinker
it checked my shoulder
it changed lanes
I I definitely feel more comfortable
with it on a highway than anything
um but also if I just
open up my camera here and point it at
this Dash
this is one of the reasons why they said
there is a yoke in these cars is because
the top half of the steering wheel would
have blocked this otherwise really
impressive view of all of the things
that the car sees and displays so it
displays the road the signs the other
vehicles around you pedestrians I'll
fire the camera up again when there's a
lot more impressive stuff to show but as
of right now we're taking an entrance
ramp to a new highway and then we'll
have to do an exit and another entrance
which is interesting light forces
steering wheel
uh what else oh there's a camera up here
in the middle of the car and what I've
noticed because I've had this beta for
maybe two weeks now is if you look away
from the road for too long that camera
will notice and it'll start beeping at
you and tell you hey look at the road or
I'm going to pull over and stop doing
the self-driving
so that's good to know there's some
construction signs up here I think it
sees them let's see it let's see it
merge there's a truck behind me I might
have to take over it I'm gonna take over
so that's a pretty good instance of an
unusual set of things on the road I'll
re-engage here
uh that it just didn't seem to pick up
where if you were driving it would
arrive at those unusual things and I'm
sure if I wasn't as embarrassed I could
have just let it figure that out for a
few more seconds
but I'd rather not do that I'd rather
just let it do its thing
on roads it's comfortable with
but as you can see it sees those cones
over there
and it is going to try to take this exit
and I don't think it's going to get this
okay let's let's see what happens it
says upcoming land change with some
cones
I would be really impressed and that
construction detected navigation on
autopilot limited says that on the
screen and yeah I'm gonna have to take
over it did not know that it had to take
that exit there
uh that's fine
but what I do know is
the actual highway driving part
is typically it's Forte
so this is what I'm calling the full
self-driving beta
but what I've
used in the past is just a much more
limited version of what Tesla calls
autopilot most people don't understand
that that's literally just basically
traffic where cruise control
um
and I mostly only use that on highways
when it's like stop and go traffic and
it's annoying to drive
so let me turn it back on
Auto steer temporarily unavailable
interesting how about trying it again
okay that time it did get mad at me
weird
so here comes the merge there's a car
behind me he let me in cool
and now there's a toll booth coming up
which I think it can also handle because
it's basically just staying in its Lane
but we'll see about that I mean I have
Easy Pass so it should follow the car in
front of me cool
apply light Force got it I'm sorry I'm
sorry toll booth detected
so it knew it was a toll booth
but it did that right
and here's another look at all the
things it sees in front of me lots of
cones
the stripes on the other side of the
road New Jersey drivers just doing
insane things that's fine
and now it sees that the speed limit is
35 miles an hour but I think when it
gets on this highway it's going to know
to bump up to
highway speed
so it takes this turn
kind of slows down a little bit
but now we're on the highway and it's
bumped up to 65 miles an hour and it
ramps up to the appropriate speed this
is stressful
this is not uh what you would hope which
is like taking the stress out of driving
and just being a passenger and looking
around and having a good time this is a
lot more making sure the car doesn't do
weird things
um okay there are three settings here if
I go into this uh settings for autopilot
on the car you scroll down full
self-driving beta has either average
chill
or assertive for the driving profile
now it's sitting here in the right lane
behind the CRV I'm going 58 into 65.
it's pretty chill
but I do have it in assertive mode and
it says that changes your follow
distance and more frequent speed lane
changes and will not exit passing Lanes
so
theoretically on the next four and a
half miles of Highway if it sees a gap
it will move over into a faster passing
Lane to pass this CRV
I also still have a little bit of
control here
because right now it sees 65 mile an
hour as its Max and that's actually
totally in the flow of traffic right now
but I'm going to bump that up
to the 10 over that it's comfortable
with
to 75.
so if it finds the gap
as I sit behind this truck here in a not
great spot
if it finds the Gap it will overtake
it'll change lanes and it will stand a
passing Lane because it's in assertive
mode
Maybe
I've been like hovering over the brake
pedal this entire time
okay
this is much more reasonable
uh parts of the drive what I also
noticed is
you know you're putting your destination
to enable this full self-driving thing
uh but it often doesn't know exactly
when to end the navigation it might
arrive at like a parking lot
or a pullover on the side of the road
where it thinks the GPS location is
where your drive is supposed to end
but it doesn't know to get into a
parking space I mean we'll get to the
studio and we'll just see what it does
um but I have a feeling we're not going
to end up in the parking spot I usually
park in we'll find out when we get there
though
see a little bit traffic up ahead
another Tesla I wonder if they're
self-driving
probably not
uh but so far it has not found any
reason to change lanes yet or pass this
CRV even though it's set to 75. it's
been comfortable sitting at 65 totally
reasonable
so yeah this is this is what it's like
getting driven around by the car
I mentioned elon's promise at the
beginning
elon's promise was kind of along the
lines of uh
these cars eventually becoming Robo
taxis which is obviously a very far out
promise and a a very optimistic looking
future
but theoretically you spend most of the
time not in your car you'd commute in
the morning you drive home in the
afternoon and the rest of the time the
car just sits around and does nothing
for you so what if your car would drive
like a lift for you or drive like an
Uber for you while you're not using it
if self-driving was good enough that
could actually work
uh yeah I don't think it's that good yet
I would not feel comfortable sitting in
the back seat of this car without the
ability to intervene as this very moment
uh there are some cars passing me a
little bit weird in the lane here kind
of ping-ponging back and forth between
the lane changes and now it's finally
deciding to Lane change confirm Lane
change into faster so use the signal to
do that
so I hit the signal to confirm that I
wanted to move into the faster Lane
now I'm in the faster Lane and it's
going to finally pass that CRV in the
middle cool
honestly I'm totally fine with it on a
highway I feel much more comfortable
with what it does in these very obvious
roads that don't have construction that
are well lined
I will also note though that Tesla has
moved their systems entirely to Vision
based meaning they just use the cameras
no radar
no lidar
and we're doing this in a pretty
comfortable set of driving conditions
visually the sun might be in my eyes or
whatever but like this is well lit
there's not a whole lot of crazy things
going on but what if it was snowing
or what if it was just white out fog or
there was a lot of rain and it was hard
to see the lines on the road
I kind of wonder if full self-driving
takes a meaningful hit in functionality
if it just works worse there
uh either way
it's signaling an upcoming Lane change
now to go back to the right lane because
my exit is in one mile
now a human driver would confidently
just slow down and pop in there right
there it's deciding not to do that it's
going to keep following this truck and
it has 0.9 miles to get over it to the
right lane so it's passing this truck
and this is one of those things where
like
the advantage of an electric car is the
instant torque and the ability to just
position yourself on the road anytime
you want
I would have made this Lane change a
long time ago but it's saying now
confirm Lane change to follow root and
use the turn signal to confirm
so I'll hit the signal but now it's got
to really figure out when to get over
I'm going to show you actually what it's
showing me on the screen which is it's
kind of picking a spot right now wow
that is assertive
that was an assertive move right there
okay
that qualifies as assertive it picked a
spot on the road
it put the blinker on and it did a
little Jersey slide
that was the best thing I've done so far
all right one last highway exit and a
toll here
now
I think the speed limit is about to
change but we'll see it's got to put the
blinker on here
there you go exit
stay on the lane thank you
and we're about to hit some heavy
braking I'm not going to interrupt
okay good very nice
the car sees a lot like it's very clear
it can see three four five cars ahead of
me and it can see the brake lights on
all of the cars around me so it knows
when cars are breaking before a human
would even recognize it it
instantaneously
instantaneously sees that which is super
cool
uh so it can theoretically respond to
things faster than I could but here
comes the exit ramp
nothing too insane here apply a light
Force to the steering wheel yeah I'm
still here I'm paying attention don't
worry
it's a big wide Lane this is a little
sloppy
but it works
it works and I think that's kind of the
motto of full self-driving beta right
now
it's kind of sloppy
but it works
dot dot
okay coming around this last turn
we've got a little over a mile to go to
the studio
it's behind this van it sees the van and
it's about to hit one of the hardest
merges
in uh
in the entire state of New Jersey which
is like
two to five and then five to two
now it's gone this is not going to work
if it doesn't see that it's yet there's
a cone here it's not con yeah I'm taking
over
so that was bad there's a cone over
there I took over and I also need to be
back over to the right which this car
did not position itself well for so I'm
going to go back into the correct Lane
here
and get around these potholes
and re-engage
so two disengagements so far
one for traffic cones on a highway that
it had a really hard time recognizing to
the point where the trucks behind me
were slamming on their brakes and
beeping at me
and two was for a cone a single cone
blocking one lane of a multi-lane merge
with a toll booth
admittedly not typical driving but as I
hopefully merge here I'm gonna again hit
the gas pedal I didn't disengage I just
hit the gas pedal the accelerator pedal
to give it a little oomph uh to make
sure it got into that merge because it
was about to hit the brakes and I was
about to get beeped at by another truck
this is the home stretch here
and I don't think there's any more crate
actually there are a little more
interesting pieces of the drive left to
go and then we'll see how it decides to
park
but
yeah so far I feel like I'm kind of in
the same place as where I started before
I got the beta which is I'd watch some
YouTube videos
and it looked like it would be
comfortable on a highway and not much
else
it looked like it kind of just
wanted to Swerve to avoid that trash bag
which is interesting
and I've even noticed it do some kind of
human things which will be like if
you're on a road with a shoulder you
need to get over you need to get over oh
you're going to the next one cool I'll
I'll be driving on a road with a
shoulder and a biker on the shoulder
and it'll move over a little bit in the
lane to give the biker more room I think
that's cool
do not hit the brakes here there's a
truck behind me
thank you
cool
uh so it does some interesting human
things and I believe that those are
programmed in and I'm glad that they
work
but it does some also like
embarrassing
old lady things it maybe it's just
embarrassing because it happens to be a
car that's capable of like great driving
um
okay one last turn here blinker thank
you
I was just dealing with these trucks now
this actually could get dicey
yep truck is right on my bumper it can
go around here
but it's waiting that's fine
I'll see what it does at the stop sign
but I'm gonna guess one more
disengagement that's my prediction
man
my heart rate is definitely higher
during this drive than the average
normal drive to the studio
it's a lot
it's a lot
breathing
I don't know let me know what you guys
think in the comments about
whether or not you trust a system like
this I mean I think it's pretty clear
you wouldn't want to be in the back seat
but even if you have a car with this
full self-driving beta which I will say
it is a beta and it is not widely
available and it's
here we go here's the last bit why are
you so far behind the truck human driver
would have moved up by now
truck has to do weird things so let's
let the truck do weird things
yep truck has to go now you go
now you go
now you go truck is still being slow so
I am still being cautious
yep go ahead autopilot's creeping
forward checking visibility go ahead
I won't disengage I'm not embarrassed
I'm just driving like an old lady
it's fine
I think
I just see the the grill of the truck
like four inches from my back bumper
like are you gonna go or not
that's that's the experience the
autopilot beta experience but yeah it's
beta so you know would you trust this
type of thing if you have the ability to
take over or would you just drive like a
normal driver I mean I live in this is
New Jersey people don't have that type
of patience
uh this truck's going kind of slow
because I think it's about to turn
and so
I almost guarantee someone's going to
beep because the truck is just stopping
in the middle of the road
but I guess everyone can see that it's a
truck and we're just kind of okay with
that
what is the truck doing if this truck
backs up I am absolutely screwed please
don't back up
please don't back up
please don't back up there's the beep I
promised
and he's stopped in the middle of the
road he's got his hazards on
and I don't think that this car knows
what to do
I believe I will have to do my predicted
third disengage after this truck flies
by me
yeah he's just got his hazards on all
right I'll just go around him
not sure what happened there
good luck to you with whatever you're
doing all right
let's see how it decides to end the
drive so I'll re-engage
and we can see
we can see that there's one more stop
sign and then it sort of turns into a
parking lot and then it dropped a pin at
the GPS coordinates of the end of the
drive
um so maybe it does decide to pull into
the parking lot and then I can handle
parking myself but I'm just kind of
curious what it's going to end up doing
anyway
creeping forward
driving forward
I've been shadowing the pedals this
entire time
and now what I was going to pull into
this parking lot well this is good
oh
chill
chill
okay
I think it's decided that it's arrived
I'll give a credit this is the front
door
that's that's enough autopilot for one
day for me
I'm just gonna pull over and take in
look at I just want to open the camera
one more time just to show you guys look
at how much
this car can see
I'm in a parking lot right now with a
pedestrian with dozens of other cars and
it sees every single one of them
it sees that stop sign right there
it sees everything there's a lot going
on with these cameras and with the the
AI processing all the data very quickly
on the computers inside the car
but I'm going to end it there let me
know in the comments what you think
self-driving or not you trust this thing
catch you guys later
peace
[Music]